pilot to Bombardier [__] uncle Joey
coming at you get that [__] bong
ready get that bong ready in that
[__] holy water because we're coming
in deep today
uncle Joey here directed with my Johnny
flambe hairdo how you [__] doing
it's a beautiful day to be alive it's
Monday March 20th the day before spring
who gives a [__]
swinging dick and giving our bottle
rockets that's the motto for today we
got the church coming up eight o'clock
tonight don't miss it and beside that
Baltimore was [__] fantastic I had
some fantastic crab cakes and Jimmy's
the city is [__] and savage I love
Baltimore now I know why they made the
wire there they couldn't make that movie
nowhere else anyway I'm back I'm
beautiful I was busy this morning that's
why we didn't do the Monday morning
spark I had [__] crack-a-lackin' I take
my daughter to the park can't go to the
park strolling around these [__]
Gentiles or Dom line one one on you but
I was stoned anyway you follow me a
little Visine goes a long way
[__]
you got perennial old G and you got LA
Confidential plus I got two sativas in
there I'm the man of many reefers this
week we got a great week coming up we
got a podcast that night Wednesday
nights and then we come back [__]
Nyack New York [__] do my old
stomping grounds the Cuckoo's Nest
tremendous quaaludes Gorilla Biscuits
[__] the Hindu had a [__] wig when
was the last time you seen a Hindu with
a wig anyway enough with the chitter
chatter Joey let's watch some [__]
reefer here today cuz if we're gonna go
deep we're gonna go deep
and don't forget I'm back as the bailiff
tonight get your DVDs ready Comedy
Central [__] getting Doug with hot
whatever the [__] hi court with Doug
there you go
I'm over there blown clouds like these
[__] half of [__] got a vapor pen to
blow I'm blowing them straight out of a
[__] bong you understand me
get some heart you miserable [__]
work it up work it up get your resistors
bong hits what ice cubes in the bong
stretch out your [__] lungs you could
Bluff don't get a vapor pen like the
rest of look at me
blowing [__] clouds you [__] you
wonder why then you wonder why they
treat you like a [__] Mook anyway I
got a nice afternoon I got a why don't
meet this dude at 2:30 they're gonna
meet some other people at 3:15 then I'm
gonna try to sneak a little workout in
there and then BAM the Churchill what's
happening now I love it when the reefer
starts going into your [__] [__]
boots another couple balls what a
[__] what are you doing with your
life nothing same [__] I'm doing nothing
we might as well see the devil together
no law against that
Oh little clouds big clouds
I'll confuse you with these [__]
things two weeks ago
Indians showed up at my door that's the
type of clouds I'm blowing oh yeah
oh well you do things are bad all over
sometimes you gotta take a loss you know
I'm saying but anyway enough with the
losses I spoke on to the boat and then
we'll see where I had is that and then
we'll take you from there
I think it's like a [__] giraffe it's
got long legs Young Saeng one minute
you're there the next minute you're
twenty yards on the floor gone what the
[__] happened to me beep beep deep in
the murky waters earlier in the world go
over the perennial get yourself a bug my
eyes are getting red right and funny
it's like Henry Hill I fee that the line
of blowing Goodfellas remember anyway
but they had a camera me
this is 100% [__] Bella Coola anyway
we're here we're queer that's it I just
want to make sure you guys alright I
miss you it was too cold and Baltimore
I'll be smoking joints outside
[__] that [__] had to sneak up to the
roof you know how we do it there's a
will there's a way
anyway I rested I'm ready I didn't go to
jujitsu today I feel bad but tomorrow
I'm ready to [__] go you understand
me and beside that we got the podcast
tonight I'm happy you guys gonna be
around I'm happy I'm home for 10 [__]
days around my family I'm gonna be out
there flying but I'm excited about going
to [__] Nyack are you kidding me or
what I'm coming in the night before
maybe maybe maybe get some Chinese food
do Jimmy and [__] the show the next
day morning and then i blast off Taniya
Kyo
I'm not sitting that's that
the wind blew my poker you don't saying
it's an old [__] shish kebab stick
with you learn them I got the good poker
at the office sometimes you this just
good Bobby later what am I gonna do with
this [__] stick I might as well save
it for something good look it's
something good yeah he'll a confidential
got some [__] kick to it jack you
better be careful like I said it's
Monday [__] it's 130 over here
they still got your [__] lunchbox you
still got the rest today get that
lunchbox hit him over the head with it
go home and pick up a bag of weed it's
Monday don't stop never say die
it's do or die Monday I don't [__]
around on Mondays you understand me I
was up at 4:30 with the rooster [__]
sending out emails cursing [__]
out where's the [__] envelope [__]
it's Monday if you want to walk like a
Jew you gotta act like the jewelry let
me tell you anyway the church tonight
8:00 p.m. yeah 8:00 p.m. California time
and next week I'll see you [__]
at night beside that you know I got you
[__] I didn't forget about you
I miss you as a matter of fact I miss
your last couple days
cuz you guys got me in there whatever
but I'll see you tonight
eight o'clock be there be square if
you're under 18 hang up now that type of
[__] I love you see you tonight have a
tremendous day we'll talk too late
o'clock tonight